I think it's a good idea to show
what our army is capable of and
what price this war is giving us, it's a
victory against the Russians, to show how
badly they fight and raise our spirits
because it's important to see such
tangible victories, examples of our victories.
I really liked the idea of ​​what they
put up  this technique and I want the
whole world to see it, to have it on
Instagram and Tik Tok. I myself will
put it up because, well, Russia really needs to
see what we can do with them. I am
proud of the Armed Forces of Ukraine. Glory to Ukraine and glory to the Heroes.
I am watching and it is all terrible
It's really true and it's all terrible, it's all
terrible, it's all that kills a
person, children, kills, kills everyone, even
all
sane people who can
do anything not only for their
country, but even for the whole world